[Música]
estamos en nuestro estudio virtual con
mariano franco del proyecto capítulo y
su grupo invisible mariano bienvenido
gracias gracias en esta expo limitación
nunca le he hecho esta pregunta eso está
en el capítulo en este proyecto claro
ahora tengo muchos colaboradores
signar los dos no están ahí son casi
invisibles entonces éste por su parte
chulo y su grupo invisible pero si
existen están por todos lados yo no lo
dudo porque ahora justamente nos hemos
dado cuenta hasta qué punto aunque
estemos lejos siempre estamos presentes
en la vida de los demás que están creo
que esta pandemia nos debes al éxito
finalmente pues sí sí sí sí una lección
y sobre todo como mucha solidaridad no
por no es artística si provocó un montón
de
pues de colaboraciones básicamente es un
poco más que la gente de pronto se vio
así como que no no voy a poder hacer
nada entonces vamos a colaborar y la
verdad ahora hubo colaboraciones en mi
disco basta de panamá
es increíble y todo mundo trabajando a
distancia
y justamente si volvemos un poco al
disco que está justamente listo ya está
disponible desde el 20 de noviembre
pasado el título del disco y el título
del sencillo del álbum es ritmo de lo
habitual y me llamó la atención justo el
nombre porque en el 2020 si hay algo que
no haya sido habitual es el ritmo de la
vida hay algún mensaje escondido en el
en el título o alguna referencia a la
pantalla en particular pues no creo que
bueno sigue en realidad cuando cuando
termine o estaba terminando el disco que
él estaba buscando un título porque el
título original iba a ser así no mal
recuerdo volando alto y después hice
esta canción ritmo de lo habitual y dije
bueno creo que es el stand track de la
de lo habitual de nuestros días que
pasan así como si como si fuera una
pesadilla no dentro de la casa
encerrados con toda la monotonía que era
habitual y entonces el ritmo habitual de
amor exorcizar ese tiempo y también es
como un lindo
como decimos a un disco de culto para mí
de los años 90 de una agrupación de
jane's addiction que se llamaba ellos
lleva el ritual de lo habitual entonces
dije bueno que creo que quedará bien
este este homenaje clint a ver y también
como una buena descripción de mis días
durante la pandemia
este es un reciente proyecto que muchos
han definido como el trópico
del proyecto como artista autodidacta
que siempre ha sido y que trabajando
industria musical de montreal por muchos
años ya el proyecto que tiene pero me
gustaría saber de diferente con respecto
a otros en el que ha participado desde
que estaba en méxico y los que ha creado
a los que ha contribuido desde que está
aquí en canadá
que tiene diferente bueno musicalmente
es diferente muy diferente yo comencé en
méxico tocando un hardcore ahí con una
guitarra tres notas y gritando
y después aquí en canadá bueno pues tuve
varios proyectos con otros colaboradores
desde metal hip hop
cuando comencé en los noventas después
rock latino cumbia y cosas extrañas pero
para bailar que fue con las aguas
tropical orquesta creo que fue como mi
proyecto aquí más grande editamos los
discos hicimos un montón de giras y
hasta el jazz fest y todo y este
proyecto es completamente otra cosa
primero que nada es soy yo entonces soy
libre
por primera vez después de tantos años y
años de años de estar subyugado al grupo
band es cierto es un placer siempre pero
bueno ahora soy libre no entonces si me
hago lo que me hace hacer básicamente no
y en esa libertad
es maravillosa pero también
es otra cosa es más electrónico todo lo
programó primero y después ya se dan las
colaboraciones y entonces vamos quitando
cosas y agregando cosas pero la base es
electrónica entonces
y también se siente creado en el disco
si es una cosa latina sabrosa va a
bailar pero también tiene algo de
electrónico y la gente dice tropiece
pong
pues tiene algo de poco me imagino
porque es un poco
un poco frenético a mí me inspira mucho
los los grupos estos de los big beat de
los años noventas como producci de los
rays y la música ready toda esa cosa
entonces creo que como que tengo un poco
de eso en la música y la mezcla con un
latino entonces imagino esos más mis
espectáculos que son un poco realmente
frenéticos ahí pues imagino que la gente
piense que es tropical pero considera
más como tropical futurista o no sé pues
suena muy bien y la verdad que viendo
las imágenes uno tiene ganas de bailar
también entonces en eso se parece
también un poco al al anterior de la
cofetel orchestra que se bailaban mucho
los espectáculos y demás ahora otra cosa
que le quería preguntar con respecto a
hacer música en un país como canadá
cuando uno tiene orígenes otros que los
de la cultura de la mayoría que tan
difícil ha sido porque usted tiene mucho
tiempo en este medio pero también se ha
desenvuelto y desenvuelto en otros
medios que es él
cinematografía entre otras cosas pero
qué tan difícil es para usted producir
su arte trabajar en lo que le gusta
obtener los apoyos de los medios pero
también de los errores de la etc
aunque como con cómo ha sido este
proceso bueno ha sido un proceso desde
el principio más remontó otra vez a lo
de usarlo a los finales de los 90s
siempre ha sido un proceso de dos años
con los docentes siempre lo hemos hecho
todos nosotros independientemente creo
que realmente no conozco otra manera tal
vez haya bueno debe de haber artistas
que tienen todo alrededor de ellos no
agentes de buques productores y todo
todo pues en mi caso y el caso de mis
amigos somos muy pobres no entonces si
no tuviéramos las herramientas
nosotros mismos para crear nuestra
nuestra música nuestro concepto el arte
los vídeos que hemos hecho y que hago
ahora pues no tendríamos realmente nada
no tenemos que estar gastando dinero y
dinero en eventos siempre es un trabajo
y mucho trabajo no bastar con este disco
comenzó hace dos años en el 2017 saqué
mi primer disco que también fue una cosa
de dos años y ahora a partir del 2018
comencé a escribir estas canciones y en
el 2019
en 2020 a principios de 2020 antes de la
pandemia pues digo así porque no sé si
fue a principios de este año oa finales
del otro en web
y ahí va a sacar el disco y llevo todo
esto y se paró entonces siempre es un
proceso de trabajo de escribir de
escribir de grabar de grabar de tocar
puertas de mandar un montón de mensajes
de hacer el vídeo
me firmo yo mismo
o sea que tengo realmente aquí mi equipo
porque también hago cine hago vídeo y
bueno estoy equipado un poco y tengo un
poco de emoción de esas cosas y me firmó
yo y hago mis experimentos visuales y
bueno esta medalla es un poquito como de
estilo no nos da la gente dice va
nuestro poquito loco acá el papichulo y
me separa un poco pero pues no es una
cuestión que quiere hacer diferente es
que soy diferente porque no tengo otra
opción aunque realmente tengo que decir
que para este disco perdón si tuve un
poco de apoyo del consejo de artes
perdón y del consejo de artes de canadá
sí me dio un poco de apoyo para terminar
esto y ponerlo ahí donde está
ahora una de las cosas que se ha dicho
muchísimo durante la pandemia es que el
mundo del arte vivo se le llama es el
arte de la música del teatro de todo lo
que se presenta en espectáculo
finalmente de los artes vivos está
sufriendo mucho porque justamente todos
los teatros están cerrados como como ve
usted la perspectiva de la presentación
del disco al público en persona digamos
en directo con la gente como como pues
bueno no hay yo hasta hasta ahorita no
tenemos realmente
cómo presentarlo lo que vamos a hacer
pronto en dos semanas es que nos vamos a
juntar pocos algunos de los
colaboradores y vamos a filmar un live
session vamos a tocar y vamos a hacer
eso sin público lógicamente y lo vamos a
tener ahí como bueno testimonio visual
de lo que fue este disco no esperando
que el próximo año pues se regrese a una
normalidad y que podamos eventualmente
pues hacer florecer esto no sé si lo
vamos a lograr creo que desgraciadamente
muchos músicos muchos artistas van a
tener que vivir con esto y tratar como
de mantener vigentes sus proyectos
en línea a través del internet todos los
medios videoclips no sé que usted
realmente la tengo que la creatividad
para mantenernos vivos y esperar que
posiblemente a finales de la primavera
en el verano podremos afuera hacer algún
tipo de shows y la gente todavía se
acuerda de nosotros no y pues mientras
bueno trabajar en algo nuevo
esperando que cuando regresemos a una
normalidad pues podamos como que tener
algo ahí listo entonces esta es así así
es la perspectiva
pues mariano franco mucha suerte en la
presentación en la comunicación en la
difusión de este nuevo proyecto de este
nuevo álbum y de su nuevo proyecto
también para título y su grupo invisible
muchas veces como siempre
[Música]